ho ho ho Merry
Christmas all right well it's Christmas
time and um because I am so loved around
here I have been given I'm told gifts by
everyone on the crew uh which is a
little bit awkward because I have not uh
given gifts to anyone and will not be
but and still I I have received them you
know I feel like every year we do some
sort of video where I open GI
and I never quite understand it because
I don't it's like I ask Meo why are we
do we want to do the gift thing again
she said yeah we we need to do it cuz we
we want you to open the gifts and see
how you react and I said well I don't
react to anything ever so why so why is
this that's my whole thing I'm not human
especially with gifts I legitimately
hate opening gifts because I don't have
I don't know how I'm not human therefore
I don't know how to react to anything
that I receive and if I hate a gift or I
love it my reaction will be exactly the
same so I could open a gift there might
there could be $10 million in this box
and then there could be like the Bubonic
plague and another one of these and my
reaction will be the same to both of
those things even though I really prefer
the $10 million but anyway I don't know
who these gifts are this is secret santa
they're not labeled so I don't know I
don't know who on the crew is giving
each of these gifts I'm going to open
them and um because this is part of the
Christmas spirit of gratitude I'll be
ranking the gifts based on which one I
hate the least this is our first gift
nice wrapping job I'll say that
[Music]
much right or racist the party game
about
stereotypes okay open the box all I
can't it's in plastic I can't I don't
have nails not going to use my teeth to
open this on camera what I need to
basically know is is is this game
supposed to be is this ironic or is is
this serious is my question right or
racist that's the gift can I actually
keep these are these are these gifts
really mine yes that's not just for a
bit okay I'll actually play this so
we're we're starting surprisingly well I
will say right or racist stereotype the
average Russian male consumes more than
five drinks per day pon.com 2014 reports
oh I get it so you start with a fact and
then you have to
decide whether the fact is right or
racist but doesn't that assume that it's
an either or question like can it be
right and racist the average Russian
male consumes more than five drinks a
day five drinks a day I'm going to say
that that
is I'm going to say that's
correct that's right I mean what the
else are you going to do in Siberia
right the average Russian milk consumes
five drinks a day that cannot actually
be correct can we can we fact check that
how has your liver not like fallen out
of your ass by by that point this is
good I I like this game I thought these
were all going to be gifts that I would
hate maybe I'm supposed to hate this all
right let's move on to the next one I
like this this is good whoever bought
that will not that's the GI so so the
the the thing here is that I'm going to
rank them at the end and whoever gave
the least worst gift will not be
fired oh these
[Music]
socks I kind of like these
two you know as you probably know I'm a
sock fan and we've got some cat paulw
socks and I'm always looking for
Creative new socks I'm especially
looking for socks I can wear around the
house and my wife can look at me and go
are you really wearing those and I can
say yes I'm really wearing them this is
happening this is happening right now
whether you like it or not so the
apparently the the YouTube video here is
just me receiving gifts that I
legitimately like it's nice to have you
know it's nice to do a video where I can
be happy for a
change once every 5 and 1/2 years it's
nice to have a video up a Richard
Simmons Chia Pet I have not seen Chia
Pets in
decades you know kids um so what's the
Chet the Chia Pet is like you pour water
on it and then it's uh and the and the
plant grows I guess is the idea they
used to have these way this is uh kids
back in the day this is what we had
maybe not Richard Simmons Chets
but stuff like this this is what we
didn't have we didn't have all the video
games well we did but I didn't I only
ever had super
and we didn't have TVs you know well I
mean we did but we didn't it wasn't the
same we didn't have internet we didn't
have social media we had Shia pets which
is just a plant that you put on your
table and you water it and then you sit
there and you just watch it grow all
day that's weeks of
entertainment so I like this too we're
three for
three am I supposed to like these gifts
not not particularly but I'm glad you do
[Applause]
all
right so these these gifts were not
given in the Christmas spirit but
they're being received I am not
receiving them in the spirit that they
were intended I am K oh that's the
Barbie movie okay now we finally we
finally got into the pile um we finally
made it I thought I thought this would
be the one video where I could just like
stuff and that could be it why can't
that be a video why can't we just do a
video where I like things do I have to
hate everything all the
time you know get criticized by the
audience frequently why do you hate
everything well it's not my fault I'm
put in positions to hate things what do
you want me to do with this you want me
to not hate it that's a strong Contender
for the bottom of the
list got some nice weight to it feel
like a paper weight I like paper weights
I don't use paper but nice to have on
the desk
anyway it's a candle and it says smell
me you know I've learned in life that
when you're anonymously handed an object
and told to sniff it it's never a good
idea
but I will anyway oh my God holy why did
I take such a big whiff of that why I
knew exactly what was how I'm being set
up here and I just went full
in nose right in it why would I do
that I'm I'm an idiot that's the answer
a shark okay so it's a candle that
smells like a shark it does actually I
can confirm it smells like a a fart
together into one
jumble I don't know how they do that I
don't know how they how do you even
capture that scent in a candle what's
going on at the shark Candle factory I
don't even want to know that's offensive
I have that smell still in my nostrils
and I don't like it at all it's just
lingering
there it's just it's in the it's in the
atmosphere now now I'm ill-tempered now
I feel ill tempered as
usual what we got
now free dad
hugs what
so I'm starting to say a whole bunch of
different things and I got to stop
myself from saying them because I think
we do want to put this on YouTube I
don't know why but it's a gay dinosaur
that is offering not just free hugs but
to make it creepier free dad hugs what
does that even mean free dad hugs like
am I offering to hug dads or am I dad
offering to give hugs as a dad either
way it's uh
it's bizarre and creepy and I hate it
and I still have the smell of shark in
my
[Applause]
nose why do I recognize this is this
Caillou is this is the little bald kid
in the kid show that I hate no it's the
one punch man the anime watch oh yeah
it's the anime that I watched um all 10
episodes remember I'm I watched all 10
episodes for real in real life I
actually sat and watched cuz I'm a man
of my word but I guess I'm now just
realizing that that that it also looks
somewhat like Caillou which is so which
is the worst kid show combined with
anime which is even worse than the worst
kid show and then you have
this and that sucks also all
right I'm actually you know what I'm not
mad I'm
disappointed I am I'm actually
sad cuz I started this we started strong
I thought oh you know they actually like
me they appreciate me they want to give
me a nice happy Christmas
apparently
not well I know what you're going for
here and you want me to hate these these
panda slippers uh but these again I know
you're trying to you you want me to hate
them and I'm not going to hate him
because I actually like him and I'm a
big I'm a big slipper guy okay I'm a big
slipper fan I'm a slipper guy I'm a sock
guy I'm a bathrobe guy you didn't know
that did you you didn't want to know
that but now you do so yes am I walking
around my house in ridiculous slippers
and bathrobes and funny socks all the
time legitimately that is how I walk
around the house not a joke my wife
hates it she'll hate these she won't be
able to take me seriously as a human
when I walk around the house wearing
them and uh but I will and that makes me
want to wear them even more
so and you know what pandas I guess I'm
supposed to not like them because
they're pandas but this is this is
putting a panda to good use I wish I
wish that this was a real Panda I wish
that actual pandas had been killed to
make me slippers cuz then at least
they're being put to good
use so there I like your
gift what are you going to do about
it I'm a
gamer like a regular gamer but
gayer H I think I know who this is from
first of all and I do hate it as well
that and it's it's it's an enormous
shirt also why why is this shirt so big
why is this like 5x this is a 6xl shirt
how fat do you think I am or is this
just if they're making is it just that
if they're making a gay gamer shirt they
automatically come in 6xl or bigger it's
like they don't there's no reason you're
not going to make a small you're not
going to make a medium in a shirt like
this like no one who would wear this
shirt would be less than 6 XL so I would
imagine it's probably the smallest side
you could find and uh and it is terrible
so thank you for that okay so we're
going to start by I've been told to hold
off on this one now everything's covered
and WRA and here under rank these gifts
we'll go from worst to best there's one
winner the winner doesn't win anything
but one person won by giving the best
gift even though they were trying or
maybe they lost cuz they're trying to
give me the worst gift and they gave me
the best uh so we'll start with the
worst gift this is my ranking get this
out of the
way I'm nervous about this by the way
cuz there's a lot of buildup for this
damn thing and I don't even want to know
what's in it uh so this is our worst
gift is the shark it's still I'm telling
you it's still in my nose right now uh
shark candle the gay gamer no no okay no
definitely this one gay
dinosaur which you know this is even
more disappointing cuz if that was just
a dinosaur shirt it'd be it'd be awesome
I'd wear it if it was just a dinosaur
but you had to make it gay so that's
that's it that's the worst second
worst then we've got Barbie next in line
then the gay gamer shirt so all these
shirts suck but then from there oh wait
and then it's the Caillou one which
we're not going to grab and then but
then from there we get then we get like
to our top four where they're actually
pretty good gifts and I'd put that I'd
rank it
there I like the
socks I like the panda
slipper both of
them and uh I think the winning gift the
best gift of all is uh right or racist
so it was it's really a contest between
Panda slipper and the card game so
whoever gave this is not fired everybody
else is um and that's it we're we're not
even going to open that no you're
opening that we're not even going to
open it you're going to open it you want
me to open it way too much it's
something is something going to jump out
of this no I mean maybe who's is there
like a very small naked in this box or
something it's G
to can't even say on YouTube so I'm
going to ruin this whole video just by
saying a bunch of words you can't say on
YouTube
oh and there's a fancy little confetti
stuff in here is that the bit that
there's nothing in the box is that the
[Music]
joke this video is over that
is that is actually the greatest gift of
[Music]
all Christmas Christmas Comes This Time
each
year
w